welcome to this video playing mega jet
jet from australia sounds somehow or
something song you once all I'm sorry i
I'm really bad with those names very
good GM from from my Australia okay
playing my standard nums oh and see what
is doing against the Zurich variation
from da 3 here white has multiple ways
to play III ii form b form yeah all
possible its own as usual fairly solid
for black it's nothing spectacular but
you have a decent playable position okay
after this i think to be a ATM sometimes
sometimes you can play 98 because it
later can transfer to f 7 but this is
probably not one of those positions okay
um 97 or a 5 who's going to play a fi
first and make his expansion on the
queenside at least leading to some
trades yeah that's an interesting
position one interesting point here is
that sometimes black can play the move
b7 to b5 quite quite a nice maneuver
okay now I don't want it okay I don't
want to take really i know is playing
you for interesting maybe night edge for
coming I don't know
and I teach for I'm still just going to
take okay I probably want to trade off a
trade-off rooks on the iphone it's not a
very active position but still still
very solid
94 was good probably prevented this this
be five ideas that can undermine the d5
pawn rook c8 is a is move that I'm
preparing something like Queen da door
queen e 8 to play rook eight and look
one Andrew k8 trade of those rooks now I
have pretty healthy pieces they they fit
well with the pawn structure and light
squared Bishop is doing all kinds of
funny maneuvers in to to achieve what
exactly not not quite sure now this one
okay check but I really don't mind that
so let's get gets rid of this then go to
the fo
okay just try to to look look dangerous
or nay to not not so clear what the
queen is doing but it might be
irritating aha so hmm night age 5 or
what about c6c six move what does he
want to do queen bee three maybe I can
also just go here by the way attacking
this pawn if I go night h5 now he has g3
okay can I do something like age five
maybe maybe h5 age 49 h9 h 5 this kind
of thing
going on c8 might be an idea to attack
the spawn I can also switch back to that
white really does not have an easy job
here to to do anything ok let's see if
he has some active idea he doesn't so I
can I could could probably go for a
repetition but I'm not sure that I want
to do that can i maybe go night to g6
maybe man I thought maybe 96 and age
form like this he can go see if I but i
am not sure
ok so let's do that if he takes Knight
g6 will be nice and I'm threatening to
take and go to g1 with my queen from
this this position on a seven Queen ok
yeah but i'm not going to trade him ok
Queen a two he has Queen a three Queen a
four maybe
Quincy to quincy 223 m i can go to d7
now maybe to d7 now attacking this and
now I get to edge form interesting I can
give this check I definitely will close
down the whole Queen side
that looks nice so not easy for him to
play this now if you move say yes know
if the night moves I might have the
check on ahead I cannot sacrifice on
time working the Night Moves I take age
three he's got this check though I
didn't see that move okay i still can I
can do this I think taking age three
that's a bit risky to play for win with
with with less time but I mean you
cannot back down every time when you
have a great position enter and now wait
I can also take h3 can if for was also
possible to take once I want the night
only five or Queenie five
it's their wind with f5 somewhere I
don't see it
yeah I don't see you in long this is a
repetition yet i only have 14 seconds
and i really don't see how to win this
is this is one of those points where
little increment would be helpful why it
got pretty much pretty much out plate
but i cannot i cannot do it in the in
the limited time f5 yes this is probably
winning but i wasn't i wasn't totally
sure I of course yeah I just I just
protect this and I can just just enter
and we know all the pawns so that's
pretty simple but I wouldn't have I
couldn't have done that with them with
the limited time yeah I was quite
interesting around here um I think it's
it's equal but he was trying to do
something and in the process yeah he
here you need for maybe Drew directly
yeah i was i was trying to avoid avoid
draw us already yeah this is really
excellent yeah okay so i could have
taken on g4 here that's nice why exactly
nuts check takes yes Queen f3 is not
working why this is strong and tending
this move no no notnot I cannot let this
I cannot do then Jack with this time and
black wins with Queen g2 no not possible
for me so this was the the direct way to
to to end this game but this this was
always keeping keeping a substantial
advantage
yeah I could have taken efore maybe
that's even better I thought the H point
is also very valuable but ok I kept the
win in hand until the very final
position but ok I'm glad that there was
a repetition some available so that I
didn't do this on time ok thanks for
watching